right another video another comment
section talking about my hair the moment
I can get a haircut you will be the
first to know they're not open where I
am maybe open near you but not me I kind
of like it I might cut the party in the
back though bored with it yet anyhow
[Music]
Justice League apocalypse war dark
Justice League dark apocalypse or you
can't forget that so Justice League dark
apocalypse war is an animated movie
revolving generally around Justice
League dark or as I like to call them
nerf bat vertigo hey all that hardcore
edge that vertigo comics had not really
you still get the characteristic when on
some pretty interesting adventures until
he got repetitive talking about the
comic books that his point is and
Justice League dark apocalypse war
Darkseid is coming so Superman's like
alright folks
alright Justice League alright Justice
League dark anyone who can fight really
we got to go take on Darkseid and so
they do but that ain't the end of it now
not at all this happens at the beginning
of the movie so don't come at me with
that spoiler alert shits the setup yeah
they lose they lose badly so a couple
years later they got to lick their
wounds and possibly take on Darkseid
again and there's a lot of intriguing
characters are in very different places
now and here we go alright so it being
Justice League dark it's more or less
spearheaded by John Constantine voiced
by Matt Ryan which I'm really glad Matt
Ryan is back as Constantine from that
short-lived live-action series if that
series gave us anything is that Matt
Ryan in the hearts and minds of fans is
Constantine forever
he's reprised the role in various CW
series also the DC animated movies Ben
Constantine in there it's like Conroy's
Batman Mark Hamill's Joker Matt Ryan is
Constantine that's that Kevin Conroy is
not Batman in this one it made me sad
but I get it really I love the setup of
this animated movie I like the fact that
they lose at the beginning it just sets
it off down this final fantasy 6 kind of
adventure got to get the band back
together get the crew back together are
we gonna win I don't know we lost before
this is a very interesting place to put
everybody granted I had heard that I
have to watch the other animated movies
leading up to this and I just took the
leap was like okay maybe not took the
plunge watch Justice League dark
apocalypse war I really don't feel like
I was missing
out on anything because I did know
enough about the characters I had read
enough for the material I I know who
they are where they're coming from
granny there are a couple of times where
I mean there is a laundry list of DC
heroes in this story there might have
been a hero Rose like other day but
there was really no setup in this movie
for them so there might have been before
and one of the other animated movies
kind of shows in something like this and
a scenario like this you get more
attached to them if you watched their
story linked to the universe in which
they go down just because I know them
from the comic books it doesn't really
mean [ __ ] if I see them just go down on
screen I'm like yeah but there was no
setup here so maybe it does help out
watching the other animated movies but
it doesn't really compromise the
experience as a whole if you just if you
know the source material
you know the comics you know the
characters and just want to take the
plunge here as for some of the other
voices I already touched on Matt Ryan
Tony Todd plays Darkseid in here I
thought he did a fine job for sure this
isn't even the first time Tony Todd's
been Darkseid it's funny how voices work
the first time I heard a voice for
Darkseid for me was in the 90s with
Michael Ironside and I thought he
crushed it and every time I hear
Darkseid I compare that voice to Michael
Ironside every time I see Darkseid or
I'm reading a comic book I think of that
voice savor your moment of triumph
Superman
I remember the tree has its best
not gonna ruin that for you that [ __ ]
was epic so her as I started this out
comparing Tony Todd to Michael Ironside
which I probably shouldn't do but I
can't help it like that Tony Todd was
good maybe I see a little bit of the
Snider cuts DNA in here not gonna say it
would be exactly the same thing kind of
like if you're comparing the two
universes of two worlds the two
executions it would probably be like
Infinity Gauntlet and infinity war you
see the story in there but it is
different it's executed differently now
the story I got in terms of the Justice
League Snyder cut is that there were
three cuts along the one we got one's a
two-parter and one's a three parter in
which at a point dark side wins and that
vision that Bruce Wayne got in Batman vs
Superman that becomes reality they gotta
lick their wounds then I got to take
this guy out you feel like you see a
little of that in here whether or not
it's gonna go down like that with the
Snyder cut I don't know actually really
hope so I hope it's a two-parter in
which it leaves off there and Snyder's
like well I guess I just ensured I do a
third movie I think that'd be pretty
smart and I really dug it I just I love
it when bad guys win and good guys are
like well we just kind of got our balls
kicked up through our throat we don't
know what to do but we do know that we
don't want to live in this [ __ ] world so
in the end Justice League dark
apocalypse war I thought it was solid it
was thoroughly engaging in fact I could
have gone for it being longer usually an
hour and a half animated movie that's
fine that's right in the pocket this one
I could have gone for seeing more of
this world so it was actually sad it
ended if you don't read the comic books
you don't know the characters it would
probably help watching the animated
movies I don't know how much they're
linked I don't know if they actually
feel like a cohesive linked universe I
don't know I haven't watched them but as
someone who I have read the comic books
enough of them anyway I'm not gonna say
I'm some guru but I've read enough to
know who Trigon is I read flashpoint I
actually watched the animated movie as
well so I guess that's another one I've
seen Justice League dark apocalypse war
actually felt like in the 90s that
animated series that would have a
two-parter that came on at 8:00 p.m. on
a Friday and you knew [ __ ] was business
you knew who's going down you're like
dude the Ninja Turtles are coming on at
a p.m. on a Friday
sorry TGIF I got things to do if it
wasn't Ninja Turtles it was Power
Rangers likest who's Lord Zedd
I don't know but I'm about to find out
they're Zords they were always there for
them that's kind of what my hair looked
like in the 90s it was like that feeling
that level of epic with a bit more grit
but more violence a couple more f-bombs
led by John Constantine I love the
character and I love Matt Ryan voice
again or playing him whenever hits
live-action I would love that series to
come back or just have him be in the
next season of Lucifer come on anyhow I
thought it was worth watching worth
buying on blu-ray
all right so Justice League dark
apocalypse war have you seen it why did
you think about it or what's a good
graphic novel a good trade a good comic
book to read you know we can aim for DC
if you want indie would probably more do
it because I like dark and [ __ ] up
take that as you will whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you